مغمسه بنيامين نتنياهو في شراكات مع
اليمين المتشدد والارثوذكسيه المتطرفه ما
اثر استغراب داخل الاسرائيلي قبل الخارج
الاربعاء نشر الكنيسه نصوص الاتفاقات
الائتلافيه المثيره للجدل التي ابرمها
رئيس الوزراء الجديد فما ابرز بنودها
منصب داخل وزاره الدفاع خصيصا من اجلس
مودريتش زعيم حزب الصهيونيه الدينيه
ليتسلم ملف الشؤون المدنيه في الضفه
الغربيه المحتله التي يعيش هو نفسه فيها
خارج مستوطنه كادومي
اليهوديه كلف بحقيبه الامن القومي مع
صلاحيات موسعه لتوجيه السياسه العامه
للشرطه وياتي مع سله من القوانين التي
يسعى لتمريرها كفرض عقوبه الاعدام على
الارهابيين وسحب الجنسيه من الفلسطينيين
الذين يرتكبون اعتداءات وانهاء الوضع
الراهن الذي يمنع اليهود من الصلاه في
الحرم القدسي
بالنسبه للضفه الغربيه من المقرر ان تعترف
الحكومه في ظرف شهرين بالبؤل الاستيطانيه
المقامه من دون موافقه حكوميه والمستوطنون
سيكونون بمثابه ذراع امنيه لوزاره الدفاع
الاسرائيليه اريد درعي سيزاول عمله كوزيلا
للصحه والداخليه مع انه مدان بانتهاكات
ضريبيه وذلك بعد التمرير قانون يسمح لاي
مدان لم يحكم عليه بالسجن ان يصبح وزيرا
فضلا عن تعزيز العلاقه بين الدين والدوله
من تشديد الحصول على الجنسيه الاسرائيليه
الى ادراج ميزانيات المدارس اليهوديه ضمن
ميزانيه الدوله والسماح بالفصل بين
الجنسين في الاماكن العامه
كما تعهدت حكومه بالغاء كل الاصلاحات
الدينيه التي صوتت عليها الحكومه السابقه
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]